in this video we'll talk about
non-homologous end joining
this is a way by which double-stranded
dna breaks can be fixed
let's learn why non-homologous end
joining is really important for a cell
double strand dna break is the most
cytotoxic form of dna damage
it has to be repaired otherwise it has
multiple deletorious consequences for
example it can block the progression of
replication fork it can lead to loss of
the chromosome segment it can lead to
apoptosis if it is not reversed
so moral of the story dsb or double
stranded dna break needs to be repaired
but the question is how
and this video is about non-homologous
end joining
there are two ways by which
double-stranded dna repair can be fixed
one is homology
based repair system and another is
non-homologous end joining
obviously you can understand in this
video we are going to focus on
non-homologous end joining basic repair
system
and let me tell you why it is so
important because if the dna damage
happens in let's say g2 phase of the
cell cycle where already there is a
replicated
uh
dna that means homologous recombination
based repair system is possible because
there is a nice copy of the dna using
that as a template the
dna break in the other chromosome or
other dna segment can be fixed but
imagine a situation where the fault
occurs in the g1 phase or early s phase
in this case we don't have another copy
which we can be using as a template so
the cell has to now repair its dna
without any
homologous template how it do that
it utilize
the help of non-homologous end joining
based repair system
so let's look at the overall mechanism
of non-homologous end joining
so this is our double-stranded dna break
which will be repaired by homologous end
joining
so near the
break side there would be loss of some
nucleotides and this process of loss of
nucleotide is known as resection this
leads to production of single strand
overhangs
anyway proteins like ku-70 and 80
heterodry dimers would be recruited into
these broken ends
ku 70 and 80 further recruits dna
protein kinase c catalytic subunits
these protein kinase c catalytic
subunits recruits artemis
artemis gets phosphorylated by dna pkc
and it can actually trim
the ends of these overhangs
later on there would be recruitment of
ligase 4 and other components such as
xrcc4 xlf etc so this entire complex can
lead to
fixation of the double-stranded dna
break
ultimately the double-stranded dna break
is fixed and all these molecules are
dissociated from the
broken dna site
so this is how nhej works
question is why natj is very important
from an biological perspective nhej is
really important and if we take special
example of the immune system it is damn
important
but before that let me tell you that
nhej is very common in human but it's
not that common in bacteria
in bacteria nhej
could be found in those who form spores
such as bacillus subtilies
and this give them an extra resistance
non-homologous end joining can be found
as an underlying mechanism of vdj
recombination which is super important
to produce antibody diversity so it is
super important for b cell
so in the v dj recombination there are
multiple
d and j segment
which would be recombined in a
particular fashion to give rise to
antibody diversity so there is first
dj recombination then there is vdg
recombination this leads to production
of a specific variable segment and for
and different antibodies there are
different variable segments
which leads to antibody diversity
and this is true for heavy chain and
light chain both
anyway there are specific recombinases
such as rag1 and rag2 all these things
lead to double stranded dna breaks if
they first cleave the first strand and
then lead to the second strand cleavage
so this double strand dna break which is
generated
has to be fixed and nhej is the
mechanism by which this double stranded
dna break is fixed and the antibod and
the antibody chains are generated so the
variable region of antibody requires vdj
recombination which in turns requires
the nhej mechanism
so let us quickly summarize what we have
learned we have learned why nhej is
important
when and where does nhej take place we
looked at the mechanism of nhej and also
we contextualized what is the importance
of nhej from an immune point of view
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my facebook page so you can follow me on
facebook and instagram all the links are
in description you can support my
channel using patreon you can support me
via a
super thanks option which is present in
the right hand side corner of the video
you can click on that and pay via pay
paytm paypal and upi your small
contribution means a lot for me you can
follow me and nerdmedic in the social
media
all the links are in the description see
you in next video